what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really
interesting and exciting news about the
Multiverse Saga in general but
specifically talking about the Scarlet
Witch Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars now
with Wanda being a Nexus being and with
Kang also being a Nexus being a lot of
people have been wondering what it's
going to be like when these two finally
interact now Marvel Studios has been
making some changes lately we know that
Phase 5 and phase six are getting a
little shuffled around and we probably
are going to be expecting some delays
but in the midst of that we have a
little bit of an update on the Scarlet
Witch and her solo project if you've
been keeping up to date many insiders
have been stating that the Scarlet Witch
is going to be getting her own movie her
own true movie not in another film like
Multiverse a Madness but a film
specifically focused solely on the
Scarlet Witch so today we have an update
on when that is going to come and what
Wanda's involvement is going to be in
the Multiverse Saga we obviously expect
it to be a lot since she did a lot of
Multiverse jumping in Multiverse Madness
and since she has basically read the
entire darkhold we expect that she has
some knowledge on the Multiverse and
although yes she was technically the
villain of Multiverse of Madness she did
turn around at the end and become good
and I'm assuming that she is not going
to want the Multiverse destroyed since
her sons exist in a bunch of other
universes and if her Universe gets
destroyed she'll never have any chance
whatsoever at getting her kids back so
again needless to say at this point I
expect her to have a pretty big role in
the multiple Saga and it looks like that
could be starting off with Agatha coven
of chaos we have a lot of new reports
today from The Insider account film
Odyssey who has a great track record
with scoops and film Odyssey has come
out and given us some information about
the Scarlet Witch including what project
she is going to show up in and some
other projects as well that are going to
heavily affect the Multiverse Saga so
starting with the first report film
Odyssey states that Wanda is going to be
an Agatha show now this kind of seems
like a no-brainer although previously we
haven't really heard anything about
Wanda appearing in Agatha's show it does
simply make sense after all at the end
of one division the Scarlet Witch's big
battle was with Agatha and Agatha knows
a lot about the darkhold plus Wanda did
put Agatha in a sort of Trance slash
prison in Westview and we can assume
that that's kind of where this story is
going to start off and even if it
doesn't start off there say it starts
off in the past for Agatha they are
definitely going to have to address this
I'm assuming this is where we'll kind of
see Wanda perhaps after Multiverse
Madness Wanda goes back and releases
Agatha or perhaps Agatha manages to get
out somehow and pays Wanda a visit
trying to get the dark hold from her
however that is when Wanda will reveal
that she no longer has the dark hold and
in fact it no longer exists in their
Universe whatever reason or whatever way
Marvel may choose to connect the two of
them although they are already very
connected film Odyssey is telling us
that Wanda will appear here in this
series so expect to see her there but
after that film Odyssey states that
she'll be in Kang Dynasty now this one
is obviously kind of a given however a
lot of people were kind of concerned
that Wanda won't really be a part of the
new Avengers team because of all of the
stuff that she did in Multiverse Madness
after all she did Kill many Sorcerers
and apprentices and for all we know she
might have caused some incursions
however that is a really good reason for
her to be involved in the King Dynasty
and specifically Secret Wars which we'll
get to in just a bit but it does make
sense that the Avengers would want Wanda
on their side despite what she has done
in Multiverse of Madness because she is
clearly the most powerful among all of
the heroes that we have and clearly by
the time that the Kang Dynasty Comes
Around The Avengers or many of them at
least are going to truly know that king
or multiple variants of Kang not just
one are a huge threat to not only their
world but possibly other worlds as well
and other universes during a battle like
this this you want the Scarlet Witch on
your side and whatever kind of happens
I'm assuming they're just going to kind
of Let It Go and kind of table that for
later kind of like in the beginning of
Multiverse of Madness when Dr Strange
shows up and he says yeah I'm not here
to talk about Westview I'm expecting
something kind of similar him showing up
and saying yeah I'm not here to talk
about what you just did all of the
people that you killed we kind of just
need your help right now does it make
sense that he would trust her right away
no not really although she did have a
change of heart at the end but when it
comes to defeating a multiversal being
you definitely need somebody like the
Scarlet Witch and I think Doctor Strange
is definitely smart enough to know that
and since she basically wiped the floor
with him he knows they need her now of
course film Odyssey also says that the
Scarlet Witch will be in secret Wars no
surprise here a lot of people are going
to be in Avengers Secret Wars but Wanda
might have a pretty big role Jonathan
majors has told us in a recent interview
that yes King is a Nexus being in the
comics the Scarlet Witch is also in
Nexus being and in one division they
teased us with those Nexus commercials
that the Scarlet Witch in the MCU is
also a Nexus being so I'm assuming the
two of them are going to have some sort
of a connection but I'm also assuming
that Wanda is going to play a huge role
in secret Wars perhaps she even works
with Reed Richards to figure out how
they can get the heroes to Multiverse
travel something that I truly hope
happens but I know a lot of people are
still asking well what about her solo
film shouldn't that be coming out before
Kang Dynasty before Secret Wars well
according to film Odyssey sadly no the
full tweet from film Odyssey reads Wanda
is in Agatha show she'll be in King
Dynasty and Secret Wars but she won't
get a solo project sadly until after
Secret Wars now this may come as a shock
to a lot of people because many would
think that they kind of need to address
what happened in Multiverse of Madness
before she starts to go on fighting with
the Avengers again however like I
mentioned desperate times call for
desperate measures and of course you
need your most powerful hero there but
the good news is that the Scarlet Witch
is still getting her own solo project
and who knows what this could be about
after Secret Wars because so much is
going to happen in between in fact we
may get a better story in the movie
because it actually takes place after
all of these big events happen so I'm
not incredibly bummed about this since
she is going to be appearing in three
other projects two of them are really
really huge the new Avengers films
before her solo movie comes out that
means we get to see her three times in
the MCU then we get an entire movie for
her so I'm very excited for that but
like I mentioned we also have some
reports about other very important
projects that are going to play big
roles in the Multiverse Saga and those
two projects are shangchi and the
Marvels now we don't have an exact date
for Xiang Chi too but Rumor Has It
Marvel Studios is iron a February 14th
of 2025 release date this would put it
before Kang Dynasty which makes sense
because Shang Chi 2 is supposed to play
heavily into the plot of King Dynasty
specifically because of the 10 Rings
they are believed to be created by
after all we did see a lot of
similarities in the rings that
surrounded King's throne and his Empire
in quantumania and you can probably
already guess why the Marvels is going
to be extremely important for the
Multiverse Saga as well that is because
of kamala's bangle this had a lot of
similarities to the 10 rings and of
course this is also believed to be made
by Kang but also keep in mind there is
supposed to be another Bengal out there
there are two Bengals and Kamala only
has one the question is where is the
other and that is certainly something
I'm hoping to find out when we see the
Marvels but no doubt that the two of
them are going to be very important
because of the items that they possess
the 10 Rings and The Bangles so when
these two movies come out they're going
to be very very important for the
Multiverse Saga things are about to get
super exciting so let me know what you
think about all of this news in the
comments down below and let me know what
you are most excited for in the
Multiverse Saga don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news or live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf